alors on va faire un magret de canard
avec un mélange d'épicés alors que moi
j'ai déjà fait mais qu' on va faire avec
des épis sa toile pour y vivre ainsi de
poudre de gingembre voilà on va faire
une seule ça à côté qui va être une
réduction de poivre d'échalotes dans un
jus de volaille et qu'on va monter
ensuite au beurre noisette la très bas
et on va accompagner sa de jeunes
carottes cuites au miel et au cumin
aussi d'ailleurs
alors on prend les carottes d'abord on
va commencer par ce que parce qu'il dit
parce qu'ils fuient le plus longtemps
dans l'horreur fait son plein pas encore
non elles sont pas encore que les alors
on y vend les peines parce que voilà moi
j'aime bien cuire les carottes à la peau
mais en ce moment on sait jamais on sera
bien là et on les la voie d'accord allez
donc voilà on fait pour former le
personnel a alors moi j'ai préparé un
magret et malgré donc en maths et ça
fait deux trois personnes oui donc
donc il faut compter on va compter à
l'est soit 40 par personne
alors moi j'ai des fans puisque c'était
carottes fanes lui il garde les fans
parce que si on les passe bien sous
l'eau voilà alors est ce qu elle se
trouvait non je vais l'allumé à
converger le chauffe 180 190 degrés
d'accord chef et ensuite on prend un
plat à rôtir
oui comme ça simplement pour mettre
toutes les carottes de temps d'accord je
vais dans le canard oui et non si on n'a
pas envie d'autres matières grasses
végétales
oui ou un peu de beurre voilà le barça
sannois que si vite donc une si vous
avez un peu de l'huile ou de tournesol
d'arâches et d'en penser chantés à
l'intérieur très bien voilà on va juste
les faire on ne peut colorer légèrement
d'accor sa sur le feu avant de les
mettre au four alors est ce que pendant
ce temps avant qu'on sache enfin
maintenant on va s'occuper des échalotes
ok alors se tourner vers la sorte
c'est bien alors on a là moi elles sont
pas encore peu mais j'ai alors eu des
touches ajoute j'avais un peu anticipée
or ce soir c'est un petit truc que j'ai
comme les échalotes
on sort on les utilise très souvent en
cuisine
oui j'allais toujours d'épaulé dans un
petit cube et revoir au frigo d'accord
petite astuce c'est pour aller civile et
alors on les taille d'abord dans le sens
oui de la fibre comme ça et avait
vraiment on fait dans le sens horizontal
mandant voilà avertis tellement ok voilà
donc petit cours de taille de l'échalote
et après moi je devais me décaler voir
ici et on sait si elle les échalotes
oui parce que la victime ans quand vous
les mettez dans une petite casserole
alors petite casserole comme les
chaleurs profité pour donner un petit
avocat
pourquoi tous les côtés qui font un peu
revenue dans la dans la dans le plat au
dcti qu'est-ce que vous avez parfois
rend la maison alors moi j'ai un poil
bonnart en grains et j'ai un petit peu
de poivre blanc alors du poivre en
grains un peu de poivre en vain
vous pouvez que l'écart à que jamais
sans la venue des [ __ ]
c'est un peu comme si vous commenciez le
permet vous voyez jamais d'accord ok
donc les échalotes le poivre en grains
que je laisse en grains à exactement
donc je vais ouvrir mon poids blier et
est ce que vous avez contre vous avez
corps villagra alors chef j'ai du
vinaigre de framboise et j'ai du
vinaigre de cidre un vinaigre de cidre
c'est parfait ok je ne savais pas
j'ai dû lâcher trop de miel mais voilà
comme ça moi j'avais entendu vinaigre de
miel en fait d'accord parce que j'ai pas
de vinaigre de cidre mais cette sauce à
l'origine je la fais avec du vinaigre de
cidre
ça on le met sur le feu un feu moyen et
on voit ce qu'on appelle on va le
réduire à sec c'est à dire on va laisser
cuire comme ça jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient
presse ne plus de vinaigre que tout soit
évaporé alors la graphie argentine à 40
on va les sorties ont bloqué non on va
les faire résonner
donc on a nos carottes qui sont qui sont
rôties et on s'en occupe alors en a 6
ans avec un peu de sel bien entendu oui
donc deux jolies pincée de sel voilà un
bon tour de moulin à poivre ou vous avez
sous la main pour aller et c'est ici
qu'on commence à mettre le cumin aura
alors le cumin le cumin en poudre
alors moi je moi je réunis un grain
d'accord alors en fourrure su comment
vous voulez oui alors moi j'ai moi j'ai
en poudre chef alors le pot de miel
il est là et donc vous mettez à les deux
cuillères à soupe sur les carottes
hockey chef donc on se met deux belle
cuillère à soupe de miel ont fait couler
gentiment ce mois c'est un ciel un peu
liquide que je n'ai aussi aussi aller
voilà et on leur fout on enfourne dans
le four à 180 degrés on va prendre leurs
rapports pour ça on en aura besoin pour
la sauce de la coriandre coriandre
fraîche vous avez un et on va les
feuillet d'accord alors on va pas jeter
les tiges on va on va les mettre avec
les carottes ça donnera peut-être eu à
très bien
ouais on ne jette rien et c'est très
bien comme ça bien charpin mais j'ai
juste le rajouter après dans la dans le
le plat différentes mais là on est fiers
parce qu'on aura besoin pour la sauce
que les feuilles
alors on effeuille l'équivalent de 2,3
belles branches de coriandre
ouais oui c'est ça les mêmes quatre ça
n'est pas un courant elles sont fournies
mais voilà et on met surtout de côté les
tiges que l'on ne jette pas voilà on est
légalement dans le hockey donc on ouvre
le four et on va mettre les sièges
ok alors moi cette femme qui t'a fait
encore à cette mode histoire de on va du
matin oui allez allez jeu malgré un
magret de canard des landes
voilà hexacore on va commencer on va le
6 orléans va s'isoler sa peau d'accord
et alors en faisant vraiment des
pénuries
j'ai un couteau qui peut passer voyez
presque jusqu'à la viande d'accord au
caire et des petites rayures très
rapprochées les unes des autres
ah oui très rapprochées d'accord on va
le quadrillé oui parce que vous allez
voir c'est ça qui va permettre qu'ils
soient très croustillants sur la peau et
qui rendent la grèce dont on a pas que
toi il faut toujours un peu de graisse
et en cuir magret de canard
d'accord mais on n'a pas besoin de toute
la presse qui assurent le magret
d'accord alors petit quadrillage on fait
d'abord commencé par des diagonales
comme sont rapprochées l'une vers
l'autre on espace à peu près d'un demi
centimètre chèche
ouais ouais pas tous d'accord ok donc on
fait et quand on a fini un sens eh ben
on reprend dans l'autre sens pour
quadriller pour que vraiment on met un
petit quadrillage de magnifiques super
alors oui très bien
dans une poêle sur un peu de moyens
allez une poêle sur un ce moyen on va
reprendre le bus pendant que la fois le
choc face aux sags et c'est quasiment
réduit à 7 chez moi à vous voyez ouais
ok alors moi aussi c'était effectivement
à la pâte
réduit à sec et donc là on va rajouter
jus de volaille au bouillon de volaille
très réduit un rouge et d'un jus de rôti
vous voyez à ok alors moi j'ai fait
effectivement un bouillon de volaille
que j'ai que j'ai réduit chef tu faire
et moi non alors là on met deux gros
pour jouer 3 même si vous avez
l'équivalent de trois bons prochain 23
voyez mamaï manouche comment elle est ok
alors voilà c'est l'équivalent à peu
près voilà de 5 6 cuillères à soupe
d'accord donc on est d'accord on est le
bouillon dans dans les échalotes dans
les échalotes 1 et en crée à nouveau
réduire en fait je vais pénètre et on
remet le feu et on remet le feu sous les
échalotes dans lesquels on a mis le
bouillon voilà et on a notre poils qui
est déjà bien chaude oui ça y est ça y
est c'est bien chaud il faut que le
magret soit bien saisi assez rapidement
d'accord alors ans pour l'instant on
assaisonne pas oui on va juste de
commencer côté peau ok donc on prend un
train à gré et on les dépose côté peau
voilà au sacro-saint sa chanteuse a tout
de suite on est là on va laisser ton
dans la neige pour lui alors on veut une
loi fondée on peut à dézoner de tout du
conte qu'evian d'entrée un d'accord donc
on le retourne nous alors un t2 quart de
celle en un tour de moulin à poivre
elles peuvent encore fait aller les
familles maintenant ça que nos agents
alors le matin ça se déguste plutôt
sévillan bien entendu ok après s'être
longtemps bourgoin c'est selon alors
peut-être est-ce qu'il faudra pas
paniquer
on sera champion à ne pas l'abîmer une
baisse qui pourra gardiens pour qu'ils
reçoivent de plus tard vraiment quelque
chose qui fait les lans d'accord
notamment ton rôle sera les carottes et
bien moi je vais lozach je garde et
malgré tout des petites pommes de terre
tepa mah le tout voilà moi j'ai mis un
bol à toutes les îles et du bea
c'est grâce à toi
d'accord vous voyez la peau du malade et
anarcho maladière
on surveille notre notre petit bouton
vous pouvez l'arrêter il faut pas trop
que ça réduit d'un don vous pouvez
arrêter là et à l'impulsion de vue
d'accords fait et je vois que les
échalotes est un petit peu compotée dans
l'est ont fait un arrêt sont un petit
peu on imagine qu'elle moins bien - le
zoo alors je laisse alors que vous allez
voir enfin on va pas les garder c'est
d'accord pour préparer la ok oui on va
leur pourrir et côté les abus auxquels
il faut applaudir celle là
le coq les faux pas bien donc on remet
un petit coup de faire de ce thème et
faire un toit un tour de moulin à poivre
fabien ont fait saisir comme ça sans
qu'il ait bien puis comme ça quand il
est bien saisi oui alors vers moi - je
ne vais dans un paquebot ou fait comme
un poil pas parler tous d'accord je vais
un peu
regard de l'autre
et je rajoute à ce mélange que j'ai à la
maison qui est fermé l'angle de
gingembre de mon de coriandre de graines
de coriandre cumin
mais si vous avez voilà ici vous allez
bien ok mais alors j'ai un petit peu de
poudre de gingembre allons super je vais
le faire un outil mélange de cumin
gingembre exactement pas fait vous le
trouverez sur le seul atout du magret
allez on met la entendons sous-programme
notre petit mélange sur la drogue malgré
ça y est ok donc en fait moi je peux
prendre mon mal gré et aller le déposer
dans le cadre des carottes
ok allez prendre en compte il de pure
vérité la finissante et carottes
alors moi les carottes elle fait en
train de quoi une jolie couleur un petit
peu plus foncée ok bien doré normalement
un d'accord alors là on va continuer
est-ce que vous avez des keys oignons
nouveaux toujours échalotes caisse oui
malheureusement je n'ai que des
échalotes chef
alors on replonge les échalotes ah ok
moi j'ai pris j'ai désormais embaumer
échalotes ça va très bien alors ce qui
serait idéal et que je ne vais pas
baisser réseau voilà mais mais dans
effectivement je n'en ai pas mais ça
quand on pourra en trouver
très prochainement je
je manquerai pas de rajouter sa chef et
j'en profite parce que j'ai vu un petit
coucou de mont-de-marsan donc je pense
que ça va te faire ses plaisirs et donc
pardon parce qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de gens qui nous embrasse qui nous font
des petits coucous donc pardon en tout
cas vous qui nous avez embrassé de
mont-de-marsan
et bien sachez que ça nous fait ça fait
très plaisir à chef hélène darroze alors
j'ai passé sous l'eau moi un peu ok les
petites mon échalotes
voilà et là on va et massez vous la sécu
en deux peut-être aussi elles sont
grosses ok et voilà s'isoler ont fait
dans les deux sens émincer ont fait que
dans un sens et racoleur voilà bombers
ccc ce que nous disait betty tout à
l'heure on prend un vrai cours de
cuisine et de vocabulaire et de pratique
c'est ses cuisines et confiné des
confinés sur le figaro fr
alors ça y est ré ciselé donc j'ai fait
des rondelles palier vous avez tout fait
mais il m'en restait plus qu'une demi tu
conduis j'avais fait la bêtise tu vois
là et ça on le met avec les postures
coriandre très bien dans le meilleur
goal très bien hollande met dans un
bateau heures noisette parfait pour à
peu près vers 20 heures alors 22 g de
beurre et enlever le porte alors 20 g de
beurre que l'on porte sur ce doux alors
voilà ça va nous faire à peu près ça et
on va nous faire fondre vraiment sur ce
doux là jusqu'à ce qu'ils trouvent
attachante et non et à sentir la
noisette à devenir un peu
et ensuite que la réduction d'échalotes
au havre aki est là et jus de volaille
est bon on va là filtré à travers une
passoire vous appuyez bien avec une une
spatule en bois voilà qu'on récupère
vraiment tous les sucres alors pendant
que je suis en train de finir d'appuyer
mes petites échalotes chef je veux bien
que tu nous expliques un petit peu ce
qui se passe avec la proposition take
away à la joya alors à johnny depp va
lancer jeudi
on va lancer jeudi la position vente à
emporter au aaa
voilà qui est alors on part sur la base
des revenus entrée plat dessert on va
faire ça tous les jeudis vendredis
samedis et dimanches d'accord et on
verra après comment nos clients
réagissent qu'à comment quelle est la
marche à suivre pour plus voir alors mon
bébé sur notre site ou sur nos réseaux
sociaux on a un nombre de menu donc il
faut se dépêcher
les premiers arrivés seront les premiers
servis
il faut il faut se rouler sur le sec et
bien sûr le menu change toutes les
semaines
oui ok alors là le beurre noisette je ne
sais pas si vous vous y est à 6 cl ça y
est mon bar mais les toulousains
conviennent on va juste pour l'instant
l'utilisent pas emballé car dit il ce
passe on va enfin passer juste à la fin
c'est vraiment un truc de dernière
minute d'accord on regarde ce qui se
passe avec les carreaux tard
voyez en plante le couteau hockey à
québec où elles sont cuites je sais pas
chez vous alors aussi si ça le couteau
entre potes tout à fait tendrement et
dans les carottes
donc oui c'est cuit oui parce que moi je
n'aime pas trop cuit le maghreb le alors
je vais vérifier aussi la cuisson de mon
maghreb où se nouent pareil vérité en
fonction de votre bout bien sûr on va le
laisser reposer un peu on va passer au
dressage dans le plat il ya des sucs
alors oui j'ai un petit peu de sucre
dans mon plat dont j'ai versé il nous
restait un fonds de jus de volaille de
les verser non d'accord aussi un peu tôt
parce que c'est vraiment dommage de
laisser perdre ce gie ben voilà on fait
du sens des glaces un peu utilisé on va
leur couper aussi
alors moi j'aime bien le couper en
tranches plutôt fine à la clis on chez
moi est parfaite et en rose autour de ta
route sur les carottes voilà et on va
finir la séance à quelques instants
alors ça tout seul chez moi aussi avec
parfois avec des poissons avec du beurre
d'accord du roma avec tina elle va elle
va aussi bien avec exactement une
semaine ce terme air exactement ok alors
justement on va notamment créer le fonds
de sauce et oui la toile légèrement 3
est alors le fond de sauce on le met
dans le beurre noisette l'heure pas
encore pas encore d'accord on le fait
juste choper un peu pour l'instant
hockey et ont fait légèrement chauffer
le beurre noisette ici
où là il faut pas que le bernois est
chauffe du corps alors on va d'abord un
coup de tabac
notre mélange coriandre échalotes ou
petits oignons donc un lien très
rapidement comme ça et on en a on
rajoute alors le beurre noisette
dakarois là et on verse la somme dans
une saucière
et on se retrouve tout de suite pour la
dégustation super superbe et mon petit
jus oui j'ai ici j'ai hâte de goûter
tout ça et ben voilà on peut y aller
très bien alors je vais chercher
découvert et place à la dégustation